so for example yesterday joe biden was
specifically about a gallup poll it
showed 56
of americans were happier now than they
were four years ago
and he was asked what do you say to
those people who say they were happier
now than four years ago about why they
should vote for you
and biden literally said they shouldn't
vote for me the poll says 56 percent
dude do you not understand how numbers
work that's
that's a pretty amazing amazing
statement here's joe biden saying just
that
gallup reported last week 50 56 percent
of americans said that they were better
off today
than they were four years ago would have
been under the obama binding
administration
so why should people who feel that they
are better off today
under the trump administration vote for
you well if they think that they
probably shouldn't
but that was not the only joe biden
fumble and stumble like this should be
the story of the campaign
and the story of the campaign should be
that this guy is not going to be
president for long if he is president he
needs to get a food taster first of all
for kamala harris
never let kamala serve ut but beyond
that
this is not a person who's going to be
president in in four years let alone
eight years
okay here is joe biden stumbling once
again and saying he was running for
senate of the united states
you know we have to come together that's
why i'm running
i'm running as a proud democrat for the
senate well no no
you're you're not though so there's that
and then uh biden also forgot mitt
romney's name
he only ran against the romney campaign
in 2012. okay this is not like
40 years ago and he's mixing up senators
or something here he was forgetting
romney's name and calling him the mormon
guy
you may remember i got in trouble when
we were running against
the senator who was a mormon uh the
governor okay
okay like well done well done job biden
he is not coherent he is not with it so
maybe we shouldn't put too much focus on
the facts we won't answer questions on
court packing
i'm not sure he's capable of answering
serious questions on anything
the bar is so low for him at this point
that if he is even
mildly in the same ballpark as a topic
people credit him
with doing a great job as he did during
that cnn town hall
but this is why trump pressuring him and
then letting him talk would be the good
strategy
from here on out by the way that tactic
does work so mitch mcconnell the senate
majority leader he is running against
amy mcgrath in kentucky he's going to
beat amy mcgrath again democrats have
poured money down a rat hole running
against mitch mcconnell in kentucky
i i feel it's necessary to spend an
awful lot of time or as much time as
possible with republicans who are
capable of articulating
conservative principles and pointing out
that democrats stand against a lot of
the major institutions of american
government it's why i spent a lot of
time
on that pence harris debate where i said
like if you strip the trumpian
attitude from the trump administration
all you get is
a lot of good policy and some
conservative ideology
it doesn't mean everything the trump
administration has done is good they've
spent out the wazoo for example but
articulation of conservative principle
in a in a solid way is a winner
here is mitch mcconnell going after amy
mcgrath in their senate race they had a
senate debate the other night
and uh and mcconnell just thoroughly
thoroughly trashed her
my opponent said she's the most
progressive person in kentucky what does
that mean
that means they want to stack the
supreme court in other words add
numbers so they can get an outcome that
they like she wants to make the district
of columbia state
puerto rico estate get rid of the
filibuster in the senate
in short it's not a dime's worth of
difference between my opponent and all
the national democrats
that you've watched if you give them
control of the government
that's what they'll do this is exactly
right this is why at the very least i'm
hopeful that republicans make that
argument
in senate races around the country again
it is looking much more competitive
in the senate races right now than it is
in the presidential race
overall and as i say if republicans hold
maine
if they hold montana if they hold
georgia both seats in georgia
if they if they somehow take michigan
if they hold the seed in iowa they'll
retain the senate and that will be a
very very important thing because again
democrats in control of the presidency
and the house and the senate
is one of the scarier propositions on
the ballot
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button